(logo whooshing)
(logo clicking)
- YouTube, what's up?
So, so grateful that you clicked
and you're about to
watch a new YouTube video
but before you do,
212-931-5731.
(bell rings)
That is my texting community platform.
I'm doing a lot of one-on-one
engagement in there
and also access, opportunity,
first looks in that environment.
212-931-5731,
(bell rings)
join it now.
And now, to the video you've
been wanting to watch.
There are people in this room
who literally didn't wanna get a cellphone
because they thought their
pager was good enough
(audience laughing)
or had no interest in an iPhone
'cause their BlackBerry
was so much better.
My friends, technology matters.
It always wins.
(suspenseful music)
- [Both] Yeah!
- [Gary] You got your perspective.
(engine revving)
(upbeat techno music)
(crowd cheering)
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
- I just wanna be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(smooth RnB music)
Thank you, I'm really excited.
It's interesting, I was sitting backstage
and thinking about this talk
and I've had the fortune
of having a lotta friends
and I've spoken at other events
within the mortgage brokering community.
And, really, what's
fascinating about it is
it's a sector of business
that I feel very close to
because I have a lot of understanding
of entrepreneurship, salesmanship,
reputation, being a distributor
of multiple products.
So there's just a lot of kinship
that I feel for this room.
And it's interesting, as I was walking,
the word that was coming
through my mind was actually,
instead of what I often do in these talks
which is really try to paint a picture,
and through sheer will and
motivation and just energy,
have deep hope that I can
get one to five people
to actually start executing
on the incredible arbitrage
that is available to this collective room
to make what they want to happen
which is no matter who
you are in this room,
you need to tell a
story to compel somebody
to do something with you.
But what's interesting is the word
that really resonated to me in the back
was compassion and empathy,
which is to say I've been thinking a lot
over the last three months.
Actually, how many people
here, by a show of hands,
follow my content somewhat?
(audience cheering)
Thank you.
So some of you may know
that over the last hundred days or so,
I've been speaking a
little bit more subtly,
I don't know how hardcore you go,
about delivery style
versus what is being said.
And I think all of us, as we evolve,
and I'm sure for the people here
as you've evolved through your business,
you ebb and flow and
you get more thoughtful.
Experience matters.
It's crazy to me how much
of a business gangster
I thought I was at 22 years old.
And look, I walked into my
dad's single store liquor store
and took it from a three
to a $60 million business
as a 22-year-old to 28 years old.
So I had it but to stand here
this morning in front of you,
it's crazy to me how
much experience matters.
I thought I was great and
I'm still that same person,
I have those raw talents,
but I have the great fortune
of 20 years of experience,
and the great fortune of
listening to the community
and the comments and the feedback,
and I've been thinking a lot about
what the style in which I communicate,
is it clouding what I'm actually saying
because I sit every day,
I wake up every morning,
and I think about this room
and I say how do they not understand?
How do they not understand
that if they post five to 30 things today
on Facebook and LinkedIn and Twitter
and YouTube and get
Anker and start a podcast
while they walk down here
with a coffee and post it,
now they have a podcast.
What is happening that the
98% that follow me closely,
daily consume the podcast,
I mean, for the people that
just raised their hand,
one of the biggest reasons I'm
trying to do so much Q&A now
is I'm saying the same shit.
(audience laughing)
I'm not gonna change this message.
The reality is thank God for me,
because I enjoy this so much,
thank God for me that TikTok comes along.
Thank God for me that LinkedIn,
after a decade of being a recruiting tool,
evolves into a content tool.
Had the world not been in
a place where constantly
the place where we spend
our attention moves,
I would have been
irrelevant five years ago
because what I believe
after you have the ability
to recognize if it's podcast or Facebook
or not Facebook anymore
or MySpace or YouTube
or direct mail or email or billboards,
my ability to day trade attention,
I say it down here,
maybe it was up before,
my ability to actually
know right this second,
this second, Saturday, October, now,
not this year, not this
era, today, this second,
where the under priced attention is,
whether organic, which means
every single person here,
even if they don't have a LinkedIn account
can go home after this talk, create one,
and post something about their local town,
what it's been like for
her to be an entrepreneur,
a product or service
which I don't recommend
because too many people
try to sell upfront
instead of bring value,
the fact that you can do
that with no followers,
no context, post today on LinkedIn
and get a thousand people
to read that is remarkable.
It's just remarkable!
The fact that you can buy
Instagram swipe up ads in Stories
within a five-mile radius of your office
in the region that you sell at $2 and $3
for every thousand people
that see you is ludicrous!
So this morning, instead of my normal
I'm gonna Tasmanian devil this room
until somebody just
starts to fucking do this,
I'm kind of going with a
different point of view
of what do we need to do here today?
It's what has led me to
places like insecurity
and keeping up with the Joneses
and judgment and parenting,
'cause all these things have come to me
in the last three years
because I can't put the pieces together,
that if you've consumed
what I've had to say
on the ridiculous, thank God,
success that it's brought me
and any other company that does it,
my friends, the number one
advertiser on Google AdWords
from 2001 to 2008 was Amazon.
Amazon became the biggest
company in our country
because it understood
under priced attention
and it didn't buy billboard,
I mean, it bought a lot of things
'cause it was a big company,
but they spent crazy
money on Google AdWords
when Google AdWords
was the best arbitrage.
I took a liquor store that
was doing $3 million a year
on $300,000 gross profit
before our expenses,
with no credit line and no VC,
and in six, seven years,
built it to a $60 million business
'cause email and Google
AdWords were the right move.
If you spent 30 hours,
which I think you should
if this is your business,
on deeply becoming educated
how to properly run Facebook Ads,
not what so many in here have done
which is they've done one
little thing with Facebook ads,
their niece did it,
or some outsource social
media expert did it,
or they tried to do it and it didn't work
and they decided Facebook Ads don't work,
you know what else doesn't work?
A basketball, if you suck at basketball.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauds)
Let me make this very simple.
This is not unfair or
audacious, this is the truth.
If you run Facebook ads
and they didn't work,
you suck, not Facebook.
(audience member cheers)
This is happening!
This is happening.
And so here's where I'm at.
In a world where you wanna convince me
that I'm better off to go with you
than to go to a .com
that is doing a way better
job than you marketing,
we've got some work to do.
Let's get to the elephant in the room.
If you're gonna get out-marketed
by rocket and zebra
and schmibra and bibra,
you're gonna lose!
I don't give a shit if you make a shirt
that says brokers are better.
I'm being serious.
That's not a razz,
that's compassion to we
need to be consumer-centric.
Humans don't care!
That's not what customers do.
Customers didn't care
that the local bookstore
had been there for 44 years.
They wanted to pay eight bucks less
and have the book delivered to their home.
Customer doesn't care.
You have to understand that.
I don't care that you've
been doing this for 18 years
and have a great relationship.
If you get out-communicated,
over time, you will lose.
This is a very simple game.
The internet will suffocate everything
but the persons and organizations
that communicate best
and have the best product, right?
But the best product is subjective.
You don't know that it's the best product
until after the fact.
Of the communication part,
you know that Karen
showed up in my LinkedIn
and I'm in the market for a mortgage
and I happen to like what
she said in that video.
My friends, there's nothing
more important right now,
period, in our society,
than to be a unbelievable communicator
in a contemporary manner.
It is reshaping our societal norms,
our politics, our retail, everything.
How?
How can you sit at home
and talk to your closest
friends and relatives
about how this and social
media has changed politics,
has ruined our children,
has done all this stuff
and not feel that it can
impact your business?
That is the compassion I
walk in with this morning.
What is the lack of the bridge
that has clicked in your mind
to make you understand the following,
which is this is my fundamental truth:
this entire room should be
making 30 to 50 pieces of content
on the internet every single day.
99% of this room hasn't made
30 to 50 pieces of content this year.
That delta scares the crap outta me
and I wanna continue
to articulate in this keynote why and how.
Let's go into the how.
I think one of the biggest things
that's running through my mind
is how do I convince this room
that yesterday, yesterday, not tomorrow,
they need to either start a video show
or a podcast that they can then record
and then after it's done for an hour,
do what I do which is post-produce it
and chop it up into little pieces
which then gets them into a place
of being able to make 17
or 20 pieces of content
out of a one-hour day.
Now, what do you make your podcast?
As you guys can imagine,
no normal human being
thinks mortgage life is rad.
(audience laughing)
We can agree with that.
It's not the littiest thing in society.
But what I do believe is the following:
I do believe that every
one of you has the ability
to start a podcast that
is a small business
or a community show
based on where you live.
The St. Louis Business
Podcast Business Podcast
is a real podcast
that anybody here could start,
and let me break this down to you
why I want to encourage so
many of you to start a podcast.
I call it the high school party rule.
I wanna take you back to high school.
Now, think about sophomore,
junior, senior year,
and think very carefully
about that one kid
who wasn't the most popular kid in school
but had the great fortune
that his parents weren't
around on weekends.
(audience laughing)
That kid, as a mid-level popular kid,
had the great idea of being
the person that threw the party
so the popular kids could
come and hook up and drink.
That kid's popularity exploded
over the next year or two.
The person that hosts the
party has the leverage.
If you start the St. Louis
Business Podcast show,
and then you spend five
hours DMing, emailing,
and reaching out to all
the other business owners
in St. Louis and inviting
them to be on your podcast
named the St. Louis Business Podcast,
you, by just taking the initiative
have flipped the leverage
and now will have much bigger
business owners than you
interested on being on your podcast.
Through that, you will build
general awareness in your region
and you will build reputation
as a top-of-the-funnel lead
gen to what you actually do.
The show is about the
entrepreneurial or local dynamics.
The awareness you get from it
will allow them to figure out
what you do for a living
which will lead to biz dev.
I believe what I just said
is as important as knowing
how to balance your checkbook.
I believe that in 2020,
the ability to be a media company
or a content creator for your business
is as required as paying your taxes
and knowing how to manage your cash flow.
I also know that the far
majority of this room
and this world does not agree with me yet,
and that's fine, 'cause
that's a story of my life.
The first talk I ever gave in
1997 was not really a talk,
it was a panel with a
table about this size
in a New Jersey Chamber of Commerce event
in Springfield, New Jersey with 40 people,
and I sat with another
guy, who, this is crazy,
who was selling Yellow Pages ads,
and we were debating, in theory,
the value between the Yellow
Pages versus the internet.
(audience laughing)
This is important!
How many people here are under 35?
Just raise your hands.
Kids, listen to me.
(audience laughing)
This is not that long ago.
This is 1997.
Listen to me.
This is me on a panel only 22 years ago
when you were 13 or younger,
and I'm sitting, debating
which is more powerful:
the Yellow Pages or the entire internet?
And by a wide margin,
I lost the debate to
the 40 people listening.
(audience laughing)
There was even a point where
the guy made a joke and said,
"And guys, let's call it what it is.
"This kid thinks we're gonna
buy wine on the internet."
Which made the 30 of them laugh,
and then one nice man in his 50s was like,
hey, real quick, so how does this work?
This is literally what he asked me,
I just really wanna understand,
what I'm doing right now is
contextualizing everybody
how far we've come
to let you understand
where this is about to go
and why it's so important
for you to really get serious about this.
This gentleman asked me
if the way I shipped wine
through the internet
was taking a bottle from the liquor store
and in the basement, there was
some weird pipe I put it into
and it went to people.
(audience laughing)
The first year I collected
emails in my store
when you would come in and buy wine
and I would ask people for their email
'cause I wanted to build my email list,
routinely, people would say to me,
oh, my email is AOL@yahoo.com.
There are people in this room
who literally didn't wanna get a cellphone
because they thought their
pager was good enough,
or had no interest in an iPhone
'cause their BlackBerry
was so much better.
My friends, technology matters.
It always wins.
It doesn't care that you've
been crushing it for 20 years.
It doesn't care that you don't like it.
It doesn't care that you're sad
that kids don't go outside
and play and look at an iPad.
It didn't care when it
invented the telephone
or the fax machine or the radio.
There is a collective naivete in this room
about what's gonna happen
over the next decade,
let me paint you a very clear picture.
Unless you start really listening
to what I'm saying and executing on it,
you will not build a brand.
Brand is going to be the only thing left,
because let me show you exactly
how I'm gonna buy my mortgage in 13 years.
I'm gonna be sitting in
a kitchen in 13 years,
I'm gonna be talking to somebody,
we're gonna decide to buy a mortgage
for business or at home,
whatever it may be,
advice I'm giving to my
niece, whatever it may be,
and then we're gonna say,
Alexa, get me a mortgage.
Let's talk about that, friends.
You think it's tough
competing against people now
that are doing a good
job about Google search
and Google AdWords?
They're not even gonna exist in 15 years
because everything is going
to be done through voice
or quite a bit of tedious
decision making tasks.
The fact that Alexa and
Google Home and Apple
will 100% be the tollbooth
to buying decisions
means you better be in a game
where you're producing so much content
that when I decide I say Apple,
get me Karen Thompson for my mortgage.
Because if I say Google,
I need a mortgage,
everybody in here is in deep shit.
It's true.
And so--
(audience applauds)
For the 93% that did not just clap,
(audience laughing)
I'm not Doomsday Donnie,
I'm Get Your Shit Together Tommy.
(audience cheers)
(audience laughing)
- [Woman] Yeah!
(audience claps)
What I just told you is
not happening tomorrow.
There's nobody that needs to cry for us.
I'm explaining that I
have a lot of concern
for you 'cause I care,
'cause I come with
compassion, not audacity.
I come with compassion this
morning because of the timing
of the transition of consumer behavior
to going towards voice matches a downturn
in the housing market.
That double-sided front
is gonna be a challenge
to navigate through.
How many people here are retiring
within the next 10 years?
Before you raise your hands,
and I don't mean you're gonna
crush it and buy a yacht.
I mean you're fucking old and finished?
(audience laughing)
Hands, raise it!
Yeah, all of a sudden, it became two.
(audience laughing)
I got you.
On some serious stuff, on
some very serious stuff,
the fact that so few hands just went up,
I wanna remind you to think
about all the advancements
that have happened in
technology in the last 10 years.
And if you allow me to go back 15,
now I could talk to you about
a world with no Facebook,
no YouTube, no smartphone,
no Alexa, no Netflix.
And guys, are you paying attention?
And what, 'cause you don't
wanna post on social media?
Because you've made a subjective decision
that you don't like it?
Your customer doesn't care
if you like it or not.
News alert: I don't like it.
There's a reason I don't post
anything about my family.
Had I not been in this business,
I probably wouldn't even
have a social media account.
I'm pretty private!
I mean it!
I have no love for it.
I didn't give a shit if
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram,
all disappear tomorrow!
I mean it!
I have no interest in social media.
I have interest in consumer attention.
I was very, very into
sending direct mail in 1997
because the money I put into it
did very well for me in return
from my dad's liquor store.
I adored buying full-page ads
in the National New York Times
on Wednesday's food section
and acquiring customers all over the world
for that $40,000 vague once we got bigger.
I'm thrilled with email.
I'm thrilled with Google.
The only reason I like social media
is 'cause it matters right now.
I can't wait to be at
a keynote in 10 years
and talk about social media
the way I talk about the yellow pages.
I have no romance, my friends.
I'm just trying to win.
And when you try to win,
you eliminate your opinion.
When you're trying to win,
you eliminate what comes
comfortable to you.
When you try to win, you don't rest
on the laurels of what's
tried-and-true and got you here
because you know those are the same things
that are gonna make you leave here.
It doesn't matter what I did yesterday.
And I can't express
how much passion I have for this room
to hear me this morning.
I mean, you're here.
What I think about stuff like this,
especially on a weekend
conference, you took your time.
I know Vegas is a fun place
to come to but you're here,
so if you're here, I'd like to think
you're gonna do something
about it when you leave.
And listen, I've been doing
this long enough at this point
that I genuinely know that right now,
I'm really only talking to
eight people in this room.
(audience laughing)
I mean that.
Here's what I mean.
I'm gonna get you fired up.
Wait 'til we get to Q&A,
which I'd like to get to pretty soon here,
so I assume that's the
mic, right, for the lineup?
So if you have a question,
you should probably start lining up now.
I know I'm gonna get you
motivated and excited
over the rest of this next 40 minutes.
I feel good about that.
That's what I do well.
I just know that next
Thursday's gonna come around
and you're gonna lose something
that you thought you had
or somebody's gonna quit, and
you're gonna go to defense.
I get it.
I've been around too long at this point.
But I implore you and I hope,
especially for the hands
that went up this morning
that do know what I've been saying,
what are you waiting for?
I'm not putting that content
out for my follows and likes,
I'm putting that content out
so you do something about it.
You watching me doing it
doesn't mean you're doing it.
It's time for you to act.
And for the people in here
who didn't know who I am
or haven't heard this spiel,
please understand that the
opportunity is enormous.
I am watching people who follow me
go into your sector and many others
with no experience, no
history, no reputation,
and grow dramatically
because they're just
winning attention upfront,
their funnel is just so much greater,
and they're figuring out the backend.
Customers don't know how
good it is until they try it.
The upfront matters so much.
The opportunity is so enormous.
I have been marketing successfully
now for 20 plus years,
I promise you,
there's never been a
better time than right now.
This LinkedIn thing for this
audience is uncomfortably big.
How many people here marketed
on Facebook in 2011 to '14
and created Facebook pages,
and that was a leader to
some good business for them?
Just raise your hands.
I just wanna get a sense.
So for this very small group,
and it was a small
execution but obviously,
for the hands that went up,
we remember how good it was exactly,
and a lot of you in this
room know that it happened
and it was good and you
regret or are disappointed
that you didn't take advantage of it.
I'm standing right here
in this room right now
telling you that exact phenomenon
is happening right now on LinkedIn.
Right now, organic reach at scale,
at numbers I haven't
seen since Facebook 2013.
And if you have no presence,
your first video or written
word or audio will work.
Please call my bluff.
Please just try.
It will really work.
And once you start
understanding how that works,
what's really fascinating
is what happens next
because you know what
I love about you guys,
and I know this about you deeply,
is once you see it, then
you really get going.
It's seeing it.
You need a proof point.
You need that first closed deal you get
from a LinkedIn post,
and once you get that blood in the water,
there's a lot of sharks in this room.
And so I'm just trying
to give you a boost,
a push, a well-articulated debate to why.
And at the end of the day,
let me be very clear here.
I could care less if
any of you do anything
about what I just said.
Ironically, it's in my
best of interest you don't.
These are just one screen.
For every post you put,
it's more unlikely that I
get through to somebody.
There's only one stream.
If I'm trying to sell wine
and you're trying to sell a mortgage
and somebody else is
trying to sell butter,
it's just one stream.
Ironically, everything
I just talked about,
I would be way better
off personally selfishly
for none of you to post.
The reason Facebook and Twitter
and all these things ebb
and flow is eventually,
the world figures out
how much under priced attention there is,
and the ads and content go
in, and then it plateaus.
It's no different than real estate.
When you're the first
person to see a shitty area
on the verge of turning
and you buy up the land,
you make more money
than the people that
come four years later.
It's not super complicated.
I'm in the real estate business.
I just trade attention, not land.
My friends, this is the moment,
and let me leave with this,
'cause I see there's a lot of questions
and I think this will be better for you
because a lot of this,
you can see free online.
My friends, the last
thing I'll leave you with,
as you're thinking, for a
lot of you in this room,
this is one big game of self-awareness.
You have to figure out how
you like to communicate.
Not all of you are outrageously handsome
and charismatic on film.
I get it.
(audience laughing)
Some of you are great
writers and that's amazing.
In a world where we're so
focused on video and audio,
writing is crushing.
You can crush by writing great paragraphs
and articles on LinkedIn
or Facebook or things of that nature.
Some of you love the gift of gab
but you're genuinely
insecure of how you look.
I understand, you don't like to be judged.
I respect that.
A, I'd like to talk about that,
but B, then just record it
and put out audio files of your thoughts.
This is a game of A,
do you believe what I just said is true,
B, how self-aware of you of
what kinda communicator are you?
The communication of a human being
has been established
for hundreds of years:
written, audio, video,
and then C, are you willing
to put in the work ethic
to learn a new skill
that is required for you to be successful?
The amount of people
that are not doing this
'cause they actually don't
wanna put in the work
for 50 hours to learn
it is fascinating to me
and unacceptable at some level
in the face of the technology changes
that I know are coming to your industry.
I appreciate your time, thank you.
(audience cheers and claps)
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
I left a lot of time for Q&A
because what I'd like to do with Q&A
is get very specific too,
and I can get very narrow, so I'd like to,
so thank you for being here.
Go ahead.
- [Marc] It's on?
Oh, it's on?
- Go to that mic.
- I'm sorry.
So Gary, thanks.
- What's your name?
- [Marc] My name is Marc
Summers, I'm with AIM.
- How are you?
- Thank you for being here.
Very good.
- Good, yeah.
- [Marc] My first question is from Jason.
- Okay.
- [Jason] Hey, Gary!
Question is about company culture.
- Culture.
- [Jason] One, what would you say
the most important thing is
when building a company culture.
- Firing dickheads.
(audience laughing)
- (laughs) Easy enough!
- [Woman] Yeah!
(audience claps)
- I mean it.
And the reason it got such a big reaction
is 'cause everybody here knows
exactly what I'm talking about.
The number one unacceptable thing to me
when you have control as an owner
is to choose a salesperson
that's driving revenue
but is cancerous to the
vibe of everybody else.
It is a mistake.
You do not understand how much
hidden money you're losing.
You're looking at a two upfront
and you don't understand
that his or her 300,000
is actually casting you
500,000 on the backend.
- [Jason] Second half
was as a company scales,
how do you keep that
integrity of that culture?
- Firing dickheads.
- (laughs) Easy enough!
- I mean it!
I'm at a thousand people now
and I literally fired
one of our number one
employees two weeks ago
and that's that.
Either you care about your culture
because you understand that's
what you're actually doing
and that's the net of your business,
or you just say it 'cause
it looks good currently
in a political correctness world
and you actually don't care,
you just care about your short term money.
I make all my decisions
on my bank account 44 years from now,
not 44 seconds from now.
- [Jason] Awesome.
Well, thank you.
- You got it.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] All right, second
question is from Christine.
- [Christine] Hey, Gary!
Christine Beckwith,
president of 20/20 Vision.
You had me at your Agent 2021,
I did a real estate influence.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for having me.
- Of course.
- [Christine] I'm using
myself as an example
because I began to follow you,
and when I launched the coaching company,
I had 500 Facebook friends and
I had no other social media,
and I had a leader that was telling me
it was overblown and egotistical
and not to get in the game,
and I began to watch
your videos on LinkedIn,
I'm a 50-year-old professional,
and I thought, how am I gonna
launch and grab market share
and I just watched and I listened.
And I did what you told me.
I got authentic and I became liberated
and I said things that were uncomfortable.
And now, I two years later,
have maxed out on LinkedIn,
have all these things,
have you calling me to
come do your Agent 2021,
and I'm here to say all these
people wanna get authentic
but it's very hard to do, so.
- Because people are
worried about judgment
and people are worried
about short term economics.
People don't say things
because they're worried about
their short-term economics.
I don't know what to say.
They're scared to say something
that may cost them money now
and they just don't understand
life is chess, not checkers,
and everybody's doing
things that are so literal.
It's so much more fun
just to talk about what you believe in.
When I first hit the
scene wearing what I wore.
Literally every person told me
not a soul is gonna take you serious,
and I was like, cool, I'll see you later.
Let's see how this plays out.
I'm stunned by people's inability
to understand how things play out.
Whoever's bringing the
most value always wins.
- [Christine] Yeah, I wanna thank you
and I wanna say, to tell these guys
to take that crucial first step
and be the example for you,
so it's more of a testimony.
- Awesome.
- [Christine] But when I
took those first steps,
I had people in very loud saying,
she's gonna fail,
egotistical, blah, blah, blah,
and now we're going to
seven figures doing that so.
- Let me tell you something
about winners versus losers.
Winners don't have time to judge others.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- [Christine] Thank you.
Anyways, thank you.
- I have never in my life
taken the two minutes
to go consume somebody else's content
and leave a negative review.
Every negative review
I get or hate or troll,
I feel bad for.
I don't feel bad for me.
You literally took the time
to watch me and spit venom?
I feel bad for you!
So thank you.
- But thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
- [Marc] Our next question is from Andy.
- [Andy] Thank you for taking questions.
As you mentioned, a lot
of people come in here
and ask for advice and they
don't follow the advice,
we call 'em ask-holes,
but what would you say
for such a digitally-evolving industry,
and where, at a service
industry like we are
that's somewhat saturated,
if we did one thing, one
thing of advice after this,
what would you say that would--
- Put out 50 pieces of content a day.
- [Andy] Okay.
- My friend, everything is a commodity.
You've got it right.
Why do you think I'm trying
to get everybody here
to build a brand?
The only thing on Earth that's
not commoditized is brand.
Do you understand what this
little fucking swoosh is?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- This fucking sneaker is a commodity!
You and I can make this
right now in China,
but this fucking swoosh
is worth a trillion.
People are fucking confused out here.
Every one of you is
wearing clothes right now
that's a commodity but
you chose it for a reason.
Do you understand?
It's only brand.
What, you're gonna try
so much harder for me
than the person sitting
to the table next to you?
Get outta here!
What, you've been doing it for so long?
This is a commodity.
You're all in the commodity business.
You're a fuckin' commodity.
What's not a commodity is your ability
to make people know who you are.
- [Andy] Thank you.
- And.
And this is why it's so interesting,
now as I'm getting older,
it's interesting to see
how my books came out.
My first book was "Crush It!" in 2009,
pretty much what I'm saying right now.
Thank you.
My second book was called
"The Thank You Economy"
which is really interesting
because the other thing
that's not a commodity
is how many people here,
after they did a deal with
somebody on a mortgage,
came back a year later and
called that person and said,
hey, how are things going?
Or sent the fruit basket and said,
hey, a year ago, we did business,
I just wanted to say thank you,
that meant a lot to me,
here's some bananas and
oranges, have a good day.
That is not a commodity.
People aren't doing that here
because you're moving
on to the next attack.
You're in the acquisition business,
you're not in a lifetime value business.
That fruit basket that you
sent that just says thank you
is such an unusual move that
that person also has a niece
or an aunt that's in the market
and you get reminded we don't do that.
So the commodity is what you do.
The whole game for everybody is room
for hyper growth or massive
decline is what they do upfront
and what they do at the end.
All the value is always here.
The middle's the commodity.
And with the internet,
the middle becomes way more
commoditized real, real fast.
And we can sit and dream what
we want the customers to think
or we could start paying attention
to how they're actually acting.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Thanks again.
Our next question is from Chris.
- [Chris] Hey, Gary, thank
you for taking questions.
Christopher Griffith, vetted VA.
One piece of your
content about a month ago
changed my opinion of you.
It's called "A Tribute To
My Friend Nipsey Hussle".
One thing that I realized from
my time in the Marine Corps
as a leader is if nothing
else, he's a protector,
and one thing I think that
excites people about you
is even though you're vulgar
and you have your mannerisms,
ultimately, you fight for
those who are disenfranchised.
- I do.
- Of that one podcast,
led me down a rabbit hole of many more.
Right now, in my opinion,
the biggest disenfranchised consumer
that it's identifiable by class
in The U.S. housing market is the veteran.
Veterans are targeted,
they're overcharged,
(audience cheers and claps)
they're discriminated
against by ignorance,
and all of us in here,
if there's one alone that
we can place our finger on
to say brokers are better, it's a VA loan.
so my question for you,
veterans don't go to The VFW,
The American Legion anymore.
They're on Facebook in groves.
How do you captivate and convey
such vitally important
information when it is essential?
- By coming in upfront with things
that disproportionately
bring them value and are sexy
build actual relationships,
and then by month nine,
maybe start slipping in valuable
and important information.
The biggest problem for a room
like this, including myself,
is when you have sales DNA,
the number one thing that we need
is way more romance and patience
but people try to go in too hard.
To your point about Nipsey
and hip-hop culture,
and I spend a ton of time interacting,
the kinda stuff I get, as you can imagine,
especially ironically vulgar and alpha
massively over indexes
with military individuals,
and I get a lot of stuff,
it's about actually
bringing value up front,
joining 73 different Facebook groups,
and becoming part of the community.
Not your opening post is you're
being discriminated against,
let me sell you some shit.
You know what I mean?
- Perfect.
- You understand?
- Yeah.
- So this is why I always get mad
at the ladies in the business world
who go in for the clothes.
I'm like, you're a lady!
You know this is what we
do to you in real life,
we try to close too soon.
Slow it down!
(audience laughing)
Do you know the insanity
that's gonna go on tonight in Vegas?
People try to close too quick!
So it's by bringing enormous value upfront
that most likely doesn't
have as much to do
with what you actually do for a living.
It might be mindset,
it might be sharing content
from other things you like,
become part of the community
and then you start.
Here's what's amazing.
Digitally, and notice this is similar
to the St. Louis Business
Podcast concept that I threw out,
because our profiles have
the links to our business,
you can go a long time,
if not forever without even
mentioning what you do.
There's people still to this
day, when they like to razz me,
they're like, but what does he do?
'Cause I don't even mention
VaynerMedia all that often,
and so bringing value to
the community upfront,
building that relationship,
playing it out.
- [Chris] Is it being a
provocateur important in your mind?
- No, I don't think so.
Believe it or not.
And it's a great question.
I appreciate your question.
I think being historically
correct is important in my mind.
I genuinely believe what I'm about to say.
I believe the communication
style I was given
makes me underestimated
and smaller, not bigger.
And I always try to tell people like,
it's so funny, it's how I started
my talk today, be careful.
I'm up here not because I'm vulgar
or because I'm a provocateur,
it's because I've been right for 25 years.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Thanks again, Gary.
Our next question is from Grant.
- Thank you, brother.
Hey, man!
- Sup?
How you doing? Good.
- Good.
- [Grant] Yeah, so most
of the people in this room
really aren't competitors with each other.
Our main competition is the
larger giant retail operation.
- Makes sense.
- The Chase, the equipment,
and all that.
And on a recent AskGaryVee show,
you and Seth talked
about how the time is now
and that's basically
what you're telling us right now, right?
And a lot of us in this room
haven't necessarily started,
but with all the platforms,
all the different ways to
get messaging out there,
like you said, 30 to 50 a day,
where can somebody in your start--
- LinkedIn.
- [Grant] Where the big boys are playing.
- Where quickly--
- Listen, I work with Chase.
Dan Gilbert's one of my buddies.
I'm watching all this.
Goliath losses to David
every day of the week
when David acts like David.
You're not gonna outspend
those players on Google AdWords
and on TV and outdoor
media and direct mail.
David's gotta act like David.
The place where they can't
win is you being a human being
that's contextual in your
general industry or demo
and producing an enormous
amount of content.
I spend my 90% of my life
trying to get the biggest
companies in the world
away from making one
video for a million bucks
and then spending 10 million of it
trying to pound into your heads.
Watch this.
By a show of hands, how
many people here now
predominantly watch Netflix or Hulu or DVR
outside of live sports?
Raise your hands.
Look at this.
The biggest brands in the world
are spending billions on TV commercials.
Not a human in here watches
a television commercial.
(audience laughing)
If a commercial is lucky
enough 'cause somehow,
because you've dropped
the remote, get to you,
(audience laughing)
if it's lucky enough, somehow, miracle,
a commercial's actually
getting in front of you,
the first thing you do when
you know that's happening
is you grab your phone and you look down.
They're easy to compete with.
Take it from somebody who works with them.
You just have to do the other part.
- [Grant] Yeah, so that's the where,
but here's the next question: how.
How do you differentiate?
How does a local mortgage
broker differentiate
from those bigger players?
- By talking about basketball,
by talking about the
pothole on Main Street,
by talking about their aunt,
by talking about them tripping today,
by talking about what they learned today,
by admitting that they
used to be too salesy
and what they learned this week,
by talking about their mentor,
by talking about their PTA, by talking.
- [Grant] Got it.
(audience applauds)
- And to your point, brother,
and I so, I really
appreciate the question,
you think they don't care.
People are like, nobody's gonna care.
Guys, the reason we sit in
traffic is 'cause we're so nosy
and we wanna look at the accident.
(audience laughing)
We care about everything!
That's the point!
We think nobody cares about me
going to Kmart or me talking.
We think nobody cares.
Ironically, it's the
only thing we care about.
Everything else is so vanilla,
the most interesting stuff
is the nuanced part of you.
I do so much business
because I'm a Jets fan,
I like root beer and wine,
and all the nuances and hip-hop.
It's the nuances!
Everything I've done,
best practices of social media
experts was said to not do.
Stay on brand, stay in your
lane, don't mix (mumbles).
Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- [Marc] Time for a couple more?
- Yeah, I'm looking to do a lot more!
- [Marc] Oh, well, let's do it!
- If you weren't invited to be in line
and you have a question, get in line now.
- Here we go!
- Let's go!
(Marc laughs)
- [Marc] Next question is from Neil.
- [Neil] Hey, Gary!
I started following your
content about 12 months ago.
- Thank you.
- And I took your advice
and started putting out content.
Over the first six months,
I got literally nothing.
- Good.
- [Neil] I felt like I was eating shit.
- [Neil] Putting out content everyday,
no sales, just information
or entertainment,
one or the other.
- You've saved my whole morning.
Thank you for saying that.
First 2 1/2 years, I did "Wine
Library TV", nobody watched.
I did it five days a week every day.
Keep going.
- [Neil] So I almost quit doing it
because I felt like I'm
not getting any traction.
- Right, you're like screw that
Gary guy, he's full of shit!
- [Neil] Everybody in
the industry's asking me,
why are you doing this?
You're wasting your time.
- Right, you're getting one like.
You look like a bozo.
- [Neil] So I felt like shit
but then in the last, the second half,
the second six-month
grade, the last six months,
my business literally quadrupled
and my income quadrupled.
- What?
Wow!
- So.
- How?
That's so crazy!
- [Neil] People are like,
this doesn't work, whatever.
I'm like, here's my W-2.
(Gary laughs)
It's proof, it's irrefutable.
But what I've noticed as I
put out more and more content
is that the consumers
have a negative feeling
about our industry for I don't know
if that's from the last recession or what,
so how do we as an industry
change that narrative because--
- You can't boil the ocean.
You can change the
narrative by what you do.
Be a good dude.
- [Neil] Okay.
So just on a local community level?
- What are you worried about?
Your W-2 looks good,
clearly this terrible perception
isn't affecting you now.
- [Neil] Yeah, that's true.
(audience laughing)
- People get theoretical.
You want it?
It's the same way I think about stuff.
I wanna make a positive
impact on the world.
It's very important to me.
I am driven by gratitude
of the circumstances and the
parenting that I was given.
My way of doing that is not
how everybody tells me to do it
which is go fight on Twitter.
My way is to instill,
especially into young men,
because I think they don't
hear it from other places,
things like gratitude and empathy
and kindness and patience.
I give them imagery of
work ethic and truth,
not bottles and models, right?
And so that's how I plan on doing it.
I'm not worried about boiling the ocean.
One day at a time, one day at a time,
one day at a time,
and then you wake up 40 years later
and you've created a legacy.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Our next question is from Larry.
- By the way, bro, your job is amazing!
- [Man] You're awesome.
- This next question is from Susan.
- Right.
(audience laughing)
- [Larry] Hey, Gary!
So I understand the concept
of jab, jab, jab, right hook.
- Thank you, yup.
- [Larry] And building relationships
as opposed to just going
blows and so forth,
but when you talk about, say,
doing one video and/or podcast every day,
and then cutting it up into
17 pieces, posting it out,
and you're posting that every single day
something different, different pieces,
where do you post your
podcasts and your videos
versus where do you do just
your social interaction,
just your Facebook,
building relationships,
being in different groups--
- Well, it's funny.
- Where's the community?
- You post everywhere.
The right hook is not necessarily the post
and the jabs are community management.
I post content to communicate.
You post the content to
start the conversation,
then you communicate.
The right hook concept versus jabbing is
when do you actually
ask them for the sale.
After you put out all these things,
then you put out 30 pieces
of content and just start,
you go home, you put out
30 good pieces of content
up to St. Louis and about (mumbles).
When is the 31st one that says,
hey, by the way, community, real quick,
I'm in the mortgage business
and if any of you happen
to be in the market,
please email me, have a great day.
If you start with that and
you created no romance,
you're not gonna convert as well
as if you put out three or four months.
That gentleman prior to you,
the back six months worked
because of what happened
the first six months.
And so that's the concept of it.
So it's not that you just
do community management
on Twitter or Facebook.
The content starts the conversation
'cause that's what you wanna talk about.
But what you may wanna talk
about is the little league team
going three games away from going
to the Little League World Series
and the whole town's enamored with it,
maybe you go down to that game,
film it, post it, say something about it,
and now the conversation's
happening, host a party.
Got it?
- Got it, uh-huh.
- And now you're just
making relationships.
Everything that a lot of
old-school characters in this room
that have been in the
business for 20, 30, 40 years,
all the great things they
did, going to the local stuff,
being part of the community,
all that stuff, that was exactly right.
That was hard work!
That was your physical work.
You can now do that virtually.
I'm building community at
two o'clock in the morning
in my underpants.
I don't have to go to everything.
So that's how I see it.
- [Larry] Okay, and
just one quick followup.
- Please.
- As far as the nuts
and bolts of where to post specific types,
so for example, if I have--
- I got a great website for
you that will answer this.
- [Larry] Perfect.
- G-O-O.
(audience laughing)
It's true though.
The reason I spend less time on tactical,
is Google and YouTube
will show you everything.
Literally you can type
what kind of content in
the mortgage industry
works on LinkedIn.
Enter and there'll be stuff.
- [Larry] Perfect, okay.
- You got it.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Next question is from Michelle.
(Gary laughs)
- Ah!
- Hi, Michelle.
- [Michelle] I'm your biggest fan ever.
But anyway.
- Thank you.
- [Michelle] Can you post too much?
- No.
- Ha, okay!
So y'all hearing what he say?
He said no!
- Let me tell you why you
can't post too much on social.
Unlike email where you
could have emailed too much
and open rates went from 90 to 30%,
this is the brilliance of social networks.
I laugh when people are like,
these social networks are.
These social networks only make money
if you stay on the social network.
The social networks didn't
make you post racist comments.
The social network didn't
make you spew hate.
The social media didn't
show you something.
Social media is not showing me anything
other than what I wanna be seeing
'cause they want me to stay.
The reason you can't post too
much is if your stuff sucks,
they'll stop showing it.
If it sees that nobody's
stopping and watching
and nobody's engaging,
you're not gonna show up.
It's completely merit-based,
our interests with the social
networks are actually aligned.
So no, you cannot.
- [Michelle] So if I show up a lot,
Gary said it's okay.
- And more importantly,
if you show up a lot,
it means that you deserved it.
- [Michelle] Everybody says
I'm everywhere and all--
- That's the only thing
you want to happen.
- [Michelle] He said it's okay.
(audience laughs and claps)
- [Marc] Next question is from Ramon.
- The important part is
when you show up everywhere,
is what you want to be
happening happening?
That's the other key.
Because you can show up everywhere
if you just post babies and kittens.
That's the other part of that equation.
- [Michelle] I produce much.
- Well, good, go!
- [Ramon] She's always in my newsfeed.
(everyone laughs)
So I wanna talk about Facebook.
First off, I love the fact
that you're encouraging us
to go out, just learning ourselves,
instead of finding this company.
There's so much noise out there.
- So much.
- I think what happens
is we sort of shut down, and we--
- Got ripped off by this expert or--
- [Ramon] Right, you
spend a little money--
- And I apologize for cutting you off
but notice how I talked a lot about,
or I snuck in there today,
it's as important as
balancing your checkbook.
This is not I'm leaving Vegas
and gonna hire my
24-year-old niece to do this.
This is if you want to be in business,
you have to know how to do this.
So put in the 50 hours and
know how to do it because then,
you'll know how to hire
somebody when you wanna scale.
'Cause right now, you don't
even know how to judge it
'cause you don't know it.
- [Ramon] Exactly, exactly.
So help us get out of the gate.
Who are the individuals in
the marketplace that you like
as far as maybe an author?
I know we could google it but--
- No, no, no, it's not
that, it's I don't know.
I spend 0.00% of my time
looking at what other people are doing.
I read the comments of humans.
- Got it, got it.
- That's it.
All I do is anthropology
consumer behavior research
through the intel that
they're putting out on scale.
And so I'm not watching
what other people are doing,
I'm watching you and
what you're reacting to.
That's why I'm always so early
on things like TikTok or LinkedIn
because I see it happening
'cause I spend four to
six hours a day reading
what people are saying about my content
or anything that's trending on Twitter,
or things that populate
in my explore feed.
Got it?
- Got it, awesome.
- And that's what you should do.
- Makes sense.
- Because it's less about me
telling you somebody,
it's go to your explore
page on your Instagram,
click the links and see
what people are saying.
Don't look at the content,
look at the comments.
- Awesome, thanks.
- You got it.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Next question is from Daniel.
- [Daniel] Hey! Hey, Gary.
Thanks for coming today.
- Hey, Daniel.
- [Daniel] Anyway, I just
wanna touch on your comment
on producing 30 to 50
pieces of content a day.
- Please.
- [Daniel] So we have a
platform that essentially,
we deliver very, very high-end content
to mortgage advices on a daily basis.
Part of the reason how
we created this platform
was because we were content creators
and we would have mortgage
advisors screaming,
hey, I don't have the time,
I don't have the resources,
I actually cannot do this.
- Sure.
- [Daniel] And I'm sure
when you said that,
there was many people that were like,
well, how am I gonna have the
time to go out and do that?
- I can answer that real quick.
Everybody in here spends three
hours a day on dumb shit.
(audience laughing)
You know it.
Do you know how many meetings are an hour
that should be 13 minutes?
- Yeah.
- Yes!
- Let me save you time, all of them.
(audience laughing)
So that's the answer to that.
- [Daniel] Thank you.
But let's touch on the resources
and the expertise to go and do that,
and only because so many of our clients
come back and they say,
man, I'm spending so
much time on doing this
that it has taken me away
from actually prospecting
or closing loans.
I'd like to hear your thoughts on that.
- I think branding always beats selling.
Yeah!
You'll spend six months
like that gentleman
on not doing as much
prospecting and selling
'cause that's selling,
and what you'll start
investing into is branding,
and over time, branding
always beats selling.
You know what's really fun about selling?
'Cause this is where my life's at,
when it all comes to you.
You know what's really
fun about prospecting
is when you don't do it anymore.
(audience laughing and clapping)
- Thanks, Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Marc] Next question's from Brandon.
- [Brandon] Hey.
First, I know you're a
die-hard football fan so.
- I am.
- I don't know
if you guys know but the
game of the week is LSU.
- LSU!
(audience cheering)
- Versus Aggies, so little LSU
game colors there for you.
- Thank you.
VaynerSports is recruiting
LSU very heavily this year
so, go ahead.
- There you go.
All right, so first statement
I wanna make is two years ago,
I spoke at some real estate conferences
about the big juggernauts
that were coming to eradicate
and put realtors out of business.
I told 'em Zillow's your enemy,
all the places you're
buying all of your leads
and feeding millions of dollars to,
they're actually gonna
cause you to go extinct.
And it wasn't well-received.
The message was kind of rejected.
They're making three-to-four-to-one
on what they're spending on their leads
but like you said,
they're looking 40 seconds, not 40 years
because Amazon just partnered
with the largest real estate
company in the country,
and of course, it's click-click-close.
They don't need a realtor
and they're even giving
you $5,000 in Amazon bucks
to move into your house
- That's it.
Wait 'til that's 20,000.
- [Brandon] And Amazon's
getting into mortgage next,
so the second part--
- Sure.
- [Brandon] The podcast, it works.
I started a small one,
and I quit doing it for a
few months 'cause I got busy.
And the amount of phone calls I got
from people asking where you at,
when can I come on the show,
and the amount of feedback,
man, we love your show,
we love your stuff, it
was huge and so now,
we're getting back to redoing it
on a consistent weekly basis.
So my question is what's the cost
to hire you to be my guest on my podcast?
(Gary laughs)
(audience laughing)
- Right now, I don't wanna bullshit you,
I used to bullshit people
and be like yeah, and then.
There's only one hack to me right now.
So my wine brand Empathy Wines
is off to a ridiculous start.
The problem is sometimes,
your ego gets the best of you,
and I made 30,000 cases
when I should have probably made 15,000,
which would have already
put us at record levels
so if you hit up John and
Nate at Empathy Wines,
that's the one hack to get me right now.
- [Brandon] Okay.
- Everybody has kryptonite,
mine's Empathy Wines.
That's it, that's what I got for you.
See ya.
(audience laughing)
- [Marc] Hey, Gary, I think we have
to make this the last question.
- You sure?
I still see 5:26.
- [Man] Three more!
- [Marc] We'll keep going.
- Yeah, keep going.
- Okay.
Next one's from Kevin.
- I got a couple minutes.
- [Kevin] Hey, Kevin Peranio,
PRMG, and homeowner now.
Proud 4Ds alum.
- Thank you.
- [Kevin] Good to see you again, brother.
- Good to see you again.
I saw you in the front.
- Yeah, man.
- What's good?
- [Kevin] So thank you
for coming and fighting
for this group right here.
You really give it to 'em,
just plain and simple.
The consumer is gonna do
what the consumer's gonna do.
- We do this all the time, Kevin.
I wish that everybody
drank wine 39 times a day.
(audience laughing)
- [Kevin] I just ordered five
bottles from your wine tech
so I ain't talking.
- Thank you.
Thank you.
You know what I mean?
I understand that you want this for you,
that's just not how it works.
Go ahead.
And by the way, I apologize.
You have no idea what
Amazon's coming to do.
And not just Amazon, Google.
It's like people are naive.
Go ahead.
- [Kevin] So help this group right here
who's so deeply rooted
in their local community
and who we all do feel we are
better and not a commodity
compared to the online lenders.
Help us get tactical.
Talk about your 4Ds,
talk about the three people
on staff they should have
to actually brand and market.
I don't know if they've
seen that piece of content
but help them.
- If you google Gary Vee content model,
if you google Gary Vee content model,
you'll find what you're talking about.
It's just too detailed for me to like.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know this.
That's why that the thing
we do is a full day.
But it's real, it's
tactical, and it matters.
It's gonna be brand.
I'm telling you right now,
the voice thing is
really gonna fuck you up.
I mean it.
I don't know what else to tell you.
We're all gonna order our
food through it, our services.
It's gonna be a big deal.
I'm telling you, I'm screaming
from the bottom of my heart in this room,
if you don't build your
name as a reputation
and have it come out of my lips,
you're gonna be stunned
how much carnage is gonna.
Toys "R" Us, Borders bookstores,
I mean, it's gonna be long-tail.
It's gonna be local!
It's gonna be local, guys.
It's coming.
- [Kevin] Thank you for fighting for us.
Thank you.
- No, thank you.
Thank you for seeing that I am.
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Next question's from Richard.
- Hey, for the people in the back,
I've got a little extra
time because of my schedule
so if I'm not screwing
up your programming,
just add how many minutes to the clock,
if any, we have.
Thanks.
'Cause I wanna answer as many as I can.
Go ahead.
- Hey, Gary!
How are you? Richard Wang.
I'm with Veridian
Mortgage and C2 Financial.
So you talked a little bit
about the next biggest thing
being on LinkedIn and TikTok.
- Not next, current.
- Current.
- But it's important.
You keep going.
- [Richard] I have a 14-year-old daughter
and I told her I'm gonna start
putting content on TikTok
and she said, "Please, don't."
- Yeah, but who?
- [Richard] Specifically would be coming
from the mortgage industry,
can you elaborate a little bit
about the TikTok opportunity?
- The kids that were in
college when Facebook came out
and the parents said they
were gonna go on Facebook,
they said, please don't.
And the parents didn't
'cause they thought it was college kids,
and then they woke up three
years later and it mattered.
If TikTok becomes the next Instagram,
it'd be a really good
idea for you to be on it.
And if it does not and
it becomes the next Vine,
the things you would learn
by producing content for it
will help you with the next
thing that is gonna become
the next Facebook,
LinkedIn, and Instagram.
(audience applauds)
- [Richard] Great.
Real quick, what is your--
- And by the way, one of
the most exciting things
about being a parent is
to embarrass your kids.
(audience laughing)
- [Richard] I do it on a daily basis.
Real quick, what is your
most cherished baseball card
that you still own right?
(Gary sighs)
- So cherished is '90 Lee Frank Thomas
because that reminds me of my golden era
as a kid dealer from
a business standpoint.
Besides posting on LinkedIn
and starting a podcast,
the number one piece of advice financially
I have in this room is to
buy vintage basketball cards.
They are so grossly under priced.
And in the next decade, people
are gonna make real money.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
I know that was a super
left-field comment but.
(audience laughing)
But I'm selfish too.
D-Roc, where are you?
There you go.
I'm gonna clip that in nine years
when an article from the journal comes out
that basketball cards have gone up 4,000%
in the last decade so gotta
do some shit for myself.
Go ahead.
(audience laughing)
- [Marc] Thanks for your time.
We really do appreciate it.
Next question is from Dave.
- Dave.
- [Dave] Hi, Gary.
My name is Dave Coyle.
Coming to this conference has
been pretty eye-opening for me
kinda seeing myself in perspective
to a lot of other many,
many other way bigger fish.
I've been forced to kind
of be honest with myself.
- Good.
- [Dave] And if I'm honest,
my biggest limitations have
been really staying hungry
and doubting myself, and I wonder,
what advice do you have for
staying motivated and positive
and for maintaining a useful mindset?
- That's a great question.
I think it's practice.
I think it's perspective.
I think you have to practice
not valuing other people's opinions.
Insecurity comes from over-valuing
other people's opinions.
It's a framework that was instilled in you
through parenting and environment.
That's just the truth and DNA.
So I think it's practice.
For example, the reason
I'm so happy all the time,
this is gonna be a little left-field,
is 'cause almost on a daily basis,
I imagine my parents
dying, my children dying.
I'm being serious with you.
I know this is, again,
a little left-field,
but it helps me put things in perspective.
How can I be upset about a bad speech
or a business deal going
awry or something stumbling
if I actually felt this morning,
and I don't think it's meditation
but I think it's closer to
it than I even realized,
even as I talk about it now,
I just genuinely practice.
Brother, you have to
practice every day saying,
whose opinion do you
care about if you fail?
One of the reasons I love losing
is 'cause I don't care about
anybody's opinion in here
about my loss.
It's my loss.
You worry about what you're doing.
And most people don't have that framework
which leads to insecurity.
If I came here, for example,
and I was in your position
and I was auditing all the bigger fish,
what goes through my mind
is I'm gonna kill these fucking fish,
(audience laughing)
not, oh, they're better.
It's just a perspective.
It's kinda like life.
Right now, if you choose to,
and you only wanna find
negativity and bad,
it's very easy.
If you choose to and you only wanna find
positivity and optimism, it's there.
It's getting into a framework
of changing the way you look at stuff.
It really is.
It's not naivete.
It's not delusion.
It's real life.
So you need to practice.
You can practice.
Bro, it's hard to be here.
Just 'cause there's some people
that are doing it better,
there's also billions of
people that are doing it worse.
The hell are you worried about
the fucking thousand people
here that are doing it better?
What about the fucking 10
million that do it worse?
(audience applauds)
- [Marc] Next question is from Fredo.
- Hey, Gary.
- Hey, Fredo.
- [Fredo] Thanks for being here
- Happy to be here.
- [Fredo] I totally buy
into what you're saying about the content
putting everything out.
I'm a private person that
I love to put out things
that help people, to help
them grow, the journey,
but there's a part of me
that I wanna keep private--
- Brother, I've never posted
a piece of content of my family.
Everybody posts everything
about their family
'cause it gets likes.
You're 100% in control!
Good, don't post it.
- [Fredo] Totally get that.
But when I see influencers
or I see people just have a
camera crew following them,
and they, hold on--
- That works for them!
The fuck does that have to do with you?
- [Fredo] Well, that's what I'm asking!
(audience laughing)
- It's no different
than the last question.
What I do or somebody else
does or an influencer does
or what works for her or him
has nothing to do with that, with you.
If it doesn't work for you,
it's gonna break anyway.
There's no right way to do it,
there's the right way for you to do it.
Talk about bananas all
day, I don't give a shit.
You don't need to talk
about your private life.
I don't.
I don't talk about my private life at all.
I meant it when I said earlier
had I not been in this business,
it's the story of my life,
I didn't drink any alcohol 'cause my mom,
Nancy Reagan got to my
mom so alcohol and drugs,
I was clean as a whistle.
If my dad wasn't in the liquor business,
I know for a fact
I would have never drank
alcohol in my life.
And I know for a fact
had I not been in the
communications business,
I'd be sitting in the audience today
with not a single social media profile
'cause I have nothing to share with you.
I'm deeply private in my personal life.
I have a lot of business thoughts.
I have a lot of observations.
I'm deeply interested
in sharing what I got
because I know the world is abundant
and I like the feeling of
impact and admiration and legacy
'cause I'm gonna eat
and it's not gonna come
out of yours or mine
so you're in control!
- [Fredo] Okay, cool.
- Good?
(audience applauds)
And brother, as soon as your
sentence turned to but I see,
you see, that's it!
As soon as you look at anybody else's,
it doesn't have anything to do with you.
- [Fredo] Totally get it.
- Cool.
- Thanks, man.
- [Marc] Next question is from Mason.
- [Mason] Hey, Gary. Good day.
A little shaky but I've
been a big follower of you
and I hear that you're a
byproduct of your parents
and that they instilled
how you have the empathy
and the positivity,
and we fill the pipes
and you talk about an
exuberant amount of content
that we have to fill
so I wanted to ask you,
as someone who feels that
they have it all going on
and knows that they're very successful,
besides selling all your
Giannis rookie cards
and besides buying the Jets,
what would provide you value,
just like we see the people
that are providing culture
in the retail environment
and they're very wealthy,
how can I reverse engineer
that on social media
to show them what we have to offer?
And I wanna ask that by how
can I provide you value?
- You provide me value if you go
and execute on what I just talked about.
I'm gonna be good on my thing.
Empathy Wines, I need to sell.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- But other than that, in
real life, just go execute.
Listen, I live for admiration, brother.
I figured out myself in
the last half decade,
I'm like, why am I leaving
so much money on the table?
Why am I leaving so
much money on the table?
I'm like, oh, right.
When somebody grabs me at the airport
and says they were homeless
and they were watching my videos
and now this good thing is happening.
I mean, the shit that I get.
The sentence, I used to beat my girl
and then you got in my
head and made me see life,
that feels better to me than
extra zeros in my bank account.
That's me!
But wait, and I'm gonna say
something crazy right now,
this is important.
And if that's not you, that's awesome.
That means you didn't get those chemicals
and if you want zeros, do you.
But this is one big
game of self-awareness.
How do you bring me value?
Go execute and send me
the email in seven years
of how it worked.
- [Mason] Definitely.
And you've totally changed my mindset
to be way more positive.
I'd fill the ears of positivity.
So a second, can I get up on stage
and take a picture with you?
- Yes.
- Oh, yeah!
(audience cheers and claps)
- Yes, he can.
(audience applauds)
No, no, question.
- Okay.
- Yes.
- You're on video.
- I know.
I wanna take a video, man.
- What's up, video.
- Oh, right on, Gary Vee.
Thank you!
- Next question's from Daion.
(man laughs)
- [Daion] Hey, what's up, Gary?
Thank you, man, for
everything you're going in--
- Bro, you're looking super sharp.
- Thank you, you as well.
- Super sharp!
- [Daion] I love your kicks.
I would rock those, but
they won't match them--
- You are looking sharper.
Go ahead.
- [Daion] So what advice would you give
the younger version of yourself
knowing what you know now
when it comes to--
- I would look that kid
in the face and said,
you're gonna do it, just go, go, go.
I had it figured it out.
I had it figured out.
And by the way, I stand here
as someone who's driven by gratitude,
that me having it figured out
is the luxury of my parents
having sex at the right moment,
(audience laughing)
and then me being fortunate
to be born in the Soviet Union
and coming to this country with nothing,
and having a mom that was
cheap for a poor person
which meant nothing was ever given to me,
and then the compassion to
wanna give back to my parents
so then I built a huge business for them,
and at 34 years old,
after never paying myself
more than $100,000 a year
on a business I took
from three to 65 million,
I left with nothing and started over,
so you can imagine when I
tell the kids to be patient
how easy that is for me.
What would I tell that kid?
You fuckin' figured it out, bro!
Honestly!
Honestly, the one thing
is 'cause I really went a little rogue.
I think everything is best in balance.
I definitely probably
should have had a little leisure in my 20s
'cause I worked seven days
a week, 6 1/2 days a week.
I took no vacations, I didn't
hang out with my friends.
So I probably took it
a little too extreme.
I probably would like to have
a little bit more
memories and fun of my 20s
but honestly, I'm incapable
of having that regret
given how it's going and
so that's where I'm at.
- [Daion] Last question.
Big ask.
My youngest sister, her
name is Donessa Johnson,
she loves you, she recently
got diagnosed with cancer,
would you mind doing a quick
little shout-out for her?
- 100%.
- [Daion] I really appreciate that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
- That's it?
(audience applauds)
Look how sharp he is!
- Oh, yeah!
- Was I right?
Donessa?
- Her name is Donessa.
- Donessa, I see it.
Donessa, I'm here with your
ridiculously good-looking brother.
I just wanna send you my love.
I'm sorry that you're going
through this challenge.
I appreciate you consuming the content.
And DM me, let's chat a little bit.
I got nothing but love for you.
It's mindset.
Play your mindset on this one.
Mindset is stunningly underrated.
- Love you, sis.
(audience claps and cheers)
- Thank you, man!
- Thank you, everyone!
(audience claps and cheers)
Thank you for having me!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you so, so much.
Have a great conference!